a good way to understand the history of
Modern Art is to a lens of
desacralization that is a movement away
from the sacred art and let's say at
least an art that pointed towards the
sacred in the Middle Ages you know in
the Byzantine era as well and how this
this art moved towards secularization uh
towards desacralization sometimes
implicitly sometimes explicitly in the
art and at the same time it feels like
that movement has come to an end and so
we're going to look at some of the
history of some of the artists uh and uh
see what that means why do I think that
in some ways we've reached the end of
desacralization in art and how there is
an opening even within the very
Narrative of Fine Art and contemporary
art that there is a narrative for
re-sacralization possible in the moment
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so the first thing to understand when
we're looking at this question
is to to understand how Ancient Art
worked you know not just in the Middle
Ages but I would say art in many of the
traditional cultures that you know art
was integrative and in some ways that is
the meaning of art itself the word art
means to gather together things and the
way that the Ancients understood art was
in this way that's why they could talk
about the art of rhetoric or the art of
of uh you know the art of painting or
the art of poetry you know or we could
even say the art of making cheese or
making wine that is Art was in some ways
Gathering multiple elements together
towards one purpose one you know One
Vision and and so that is that is what
it means to be that is what it meant to
be an artist someone who had the skill
and the capacity to take a bunch of
stuff a bunch of materials and gather
them together towards a common meaning
of course you know but materials in
terms of physical materials but also in
terms of ideas in terms of words all of
that together and so the way to
understand the ancient art is that it
was integrative not just in its
constituent that is not just in the
things that made up the object of art
but the way in which art function in the
world that is Art was participating in
society you know if you think of sacred
art and it was used in service of God
and service of of church functions you
know a reliquary was there to hold
relics paintings were there to both to
decorate important places but then also
to remind us of what is important in the
images of the Sacred but then also you
know if you think of how castles or the
houses of of nobles were decorated was
there to of course decorate but also to
celebrate the things that were important
to people the hunt you know the the the
jousting if someone you know
commissioned a poet to come and give an
elegy to the king to a wedding or
something music was used for for dancing
music was used for celebrating God and
so there was a sense in which there was
this integrative aspect and so
this integrative aspect you know comes
you know as in this basic idea in the
middle ages of the great chain of being
that is the way in which God manifests
himself in the world and how things
participate in that you know and uh you
can see art becomes a means of
embodiment of skill or craft and there
is a desire to find unity in the
multiplicity and this hierarchy is both
in the means and the expression that is
in the in the very style of the images
there was this desire but then also you
know in the use of materials and towards
the the direction that the direction
towards the sacred and so there wasn't
only Sacred Heart but in some ways
sacred art informed the profane that is
church architecture church music Church
Art became the model the thing to look
to to know where to get the the
influences for everything else and so of
course a church building would be the
most
um beautiful and and the most ornate and
you know the the most complete building
in a city but it would inform the forms
and the structures of the rest of the
the building the same goes for art if
you look at Byzantine art for example
you'll notice that if you made a you
know
um a book that Illustrated the life of
Alexander the Great you would use the
same tropes that you would use in icons
and in sacred art because in some ways
sacred art was the highest and it
informed the lowest as well this was
true both in the East and in the west
and it was true really up to you know I
would say up to the 13th 14th century if
we look at uh for example in Florence
the baptistry in Florence you will find
you know late in late versions of this
type of art where the the baptistry is
there to baptize people and then in the
baptistry you will find a type of
imagery which is looking to let's say
integrate the the way the image is made
into a deep Theology and it wasn't as
concerned with certain questions which
would come later in in the art it was
concerned with really showing the
meaning and and also having us
understand the part participation
and so the way that it's often phrased
by
historians you know maybe a little less
today but at least for a very long time
the way it was framed by Art historians
was that there was a shift at the end of
this period into now wanting to show the
natural world you know the Ancients
didn't show the natural world uh they
showed this type of iconology this type
of uh the way you know focus on
theological meaning and not so focused
on representing reality the way that it
looks and that then in the late 14th
century
um
I would say you know then 15th century
especially is when you start to see this
kind of stuff of course this is Van Ike
um and Raphael and so van Ike is an
early example used by Art historians to
show the shift that happened where now
there's a desire to represent the
textures of reality represent the folds
in a more realistic way
um and that this is a major shift in in
art making
and then you have examples like Raphael
um you know Leonardo da Vinci as people
who are now focused on the the material
world and trying to represent things in
a material world in a different way now
it's very important to pause even here
and to to question some of the
assumptions that we have about the
Renaissance and so
what's interesting about the Renaissance
is that in the Renaissance there's a
little microcosm you could call it which
is that although it is true that if you
look at the beginning of the Renaissance
there seems to be a desire to show
visual
the way in which we experience visual
reality to kind of emphasize that
emphasize the the momentary emphasize
the the capturing the
the moment you know because in in the
ancient images they tended to represent
figures from the front faces that you
could see you know that's how you
encounter a person so if I'm going to
show a person then I show them face
first I show them you know in a way that
I can see their face their expression
that's clear and so that of course in
the everyday life you know if you're
walking down the street then that's not
the experience you have you know
although
uh you know you could argue that this
way of representing is more real because
it takes you know it
takes into account the fact that this is
a representation of a person and what's
the best way to represent a person then
this is the way that it is but of course
when you see a Raphael then all of a
sudden you see people uh you know from
behind people that you don't see their
faces people that you can see the the
backs of their heads here you know all
of that is going on
um and then you can see the bottom of
people's feet this kind of stuff that
you would never see in a uh in a
traditional an ancient image
and there's this kind of atmospheric
desire to show the sunset and to show
you know these kind of natural details
of course in Van Nike you see that
especially and so the the way that it's
often framed is that okay so this is the
major shift and then from then on there
is kind of this desire to to show
natural reality and a a desire to um
to show the visual world but I would say
that it's not completely true and like I
said there is a interesting microcosm
that happens in the Renaissance is that
it starts this way that it ends with
this
and so this is what we call mannerism
and so mannerism is a part of the
Renaissance that people don't like to
talk so much about because they don't
quite know how to fit it into their
narrative and so immediately after the
artists start to try to represent let's
say what you could call Visual or
physical reality they immediately start
to deform it they immediately start to
stretch it out and to create uh let's
say expressive deformations in the art
so this is par parmigiano uh who shows
excessive proportions here in the body
of the Virgin extremely long neck
everything is ridiculous in terms of of
natural proportions I'm not trying to
mock it because of that and then the the
body of the baby is completely stretched
out these are not natural uh proportions
and then you look at someone like
archimboldo which goes even further and
you know paints figure with flowers and
with different vegetables and different
types of
different types of details and so you
could say interestingly enough that
these artists here they are these are
contemporary artists that is that their
concerns are very much the concerns of a
contemporary artist today you know
archimboldo the things that he's dealing
with the questions that he's dealing
with are questions that are completely
akin to what you would see in a modern
installation or or in in much of Modern
Art so there's a little microcosm in the
Renaissance of the transformation that
is going to happen and the
transformation is a movement you could
say
away from the the representation of the
Sacred a representation of the visual
but the way to understand the visual to
understand why it leads to mannerism is
that you have to understand that in even
in Van Ike is a desire to show the
little hairs on the dog and you know the
little folds in this clothing and so
because there's a desire to show
idiosyncrasy a desire to show you know
the little details rather than the
patterns of the world although it's not
of course this is still all very
patterned then this will lead to what
will lead to idiosyncrasy and so there
are many types of idiosyncrasies and
this kind of idiosyncrasy the kind of
idiosyncrasy that shows exception and
shows strangeness and chose a a kind of
uh you know especially in archimboldo
you know a kind of Fantastical
impossibility is of course the end of
what we could call idiosyncrasy you know
and so the idea that the movement from
this to this if that surprises you then
you're missing out on what is going on
and you can understand now for example
why something like the Scientific
Revolution or why the enlightenment all
leads to post-modernism and leads to
idiosyncrasy because the desire to show
the the the world in its details it's a
rationally in its details and to kind of
explore the the textures of of reality
uh and looking down at the Earth and
trying to explore phenomena will
ultimately lead to something like
idiosyncrasy because you're not looking
above you're not looking at the patterns
you're not trying to say embody the
patterns you're rather trying to to
disconnect yourself a little bit it's
not yet completely clear that that's
going on disconnect yourself from the
patterns and look uh let's say down
below and so down below is is of course
detail and all of this stuff and then
all also you know it's a uh
moments that are not captured for the
reason of their meaning and so showing
someone the back of someone's head you
know looking at the at the uh at the uh
Transfiguration is is to show like an
idiosyncratic moment in that in that Mo
in what happened you know because okay
maybe someone had their head you know
you could not see their face but you
know what is the purpose of showing that
except to John to just show an
idiosyncrasy of the moment
um and you also always need to compare
it to the way in which the traditional
image would tend to show things in a
manner that was more uh that 10 tended
to be more ordered and tended to show
the pattern of reality and this this
movement this transformation you know
it's there even in the great artists
they're in their lives and so if you
look at someone like Michelangelo uh you
know the pieta has this very powerful
image you know in terms of emotion in
terms of realism in terms of showing you
know you know the the virgin's fingers
kind of uh you know in on the skin of
Christ you know these little details
like the the um the finger of Christ
that is caught in her in her clothing
like these these little beautiful little
details uh have nonetheless something to
do with this kind of movement towards
idiosyncrasy and the this movement
towards idiosyncrasy appears in the the
pieta already as something like uh a
beginning of that you see it in the way
in which her clothing the virgin's
clothing is represented so if you look
at an ancient image you know here's an
image of the Virgin here there was a way
in which although it wasn't completely
ordered the clothing was showed with a
certain uh restraint and so there was
there were patterns of fold and
everything and so it's not like it was
just completely uh straight but there
was a certain restraint to avoid you
know to show something that is
completely chaotic especially in her
veil you know especially in the Veil on
her head that would have been the case
but of course here you see you know her
clothing completely frumped and
completely mixed and this is of course
to show her emotion in this in this
crucial moment uh which like I said is
very effective but when you get to the
end of the life of Michelangelo he is
really taking this mannerism to the
extreme so if you look at the Florentine
pieta which is here you can see you know
how twisted and how strange the
proportions are look at the proportions
of this woman compared to The Man Behind
Christ who is who is holding him you
know look at how his body is Twisted how
his arm is completely Twisted how his
leg is folded in ways that are no longer
even have the subtlety of what is of
what is in this image but really push
the deformation of the body to to to
extremes this has many corollaries it
has many things that it involved
um
and what I want especially want to show
you is of course uh El Greco and so El
Greco is a great example of what's going
on in terms of art as something like
desacralization
um because El Greco in his own story
moved from being a traditional icon
painter to being a Renaissance painter
and you can see in his art
very strange things going on uh that
that we can look at so of course this
image here on the left is a version of a
traditional icon it's a it has a western
flavor to it it shows the Ascension of
the Virgin and her dormition down here
foreign
the clothing of the of the Apostles is
done in the traditional style this kind
of gathering the way in which the
architecture is shown from the outside
you know with the gold background
all of this represents uh um
all this represents a at least a
ordering on the pattern so what I want
to suggest in this move towards
mannerism is really a kind of inversion
and the inversion
appears visually you can see it visually
it appears in you know
you could say something like it is in
some ways the perspective of the earth
you know or the Earth kind of moving up
uh and taking the place of Heaven this
of course appears in the showing of
idiosyncrasy the the the
um the emphasis in idiosyncrasy but it
can be shown in many ways so if van Nike
shows it as showing the little details
of the you know the fold and all this
kind of luscious uh beautiful stuff then
in El Greco you find stranger things now
and so
if you find what I call Angel upskirts
which is one of the strangest thing in
medieval patterns so what is happening
here in this image why are we seeing up
this person's uh skirt of this person's
clothing why is this this vision of kind
of seeing up and there's a sense in
which you really do get a strange
inversion that's going on you know and
it's the same with some of the
positioning for example of these these
little this little cherub babies uh you
know with the with the leg up and kind
of
that being very careful of showing here
you know what's going on with the legs
up and kind of seeing in there it's very
disturbing what is happening and so why
is this happening you know and it really
is a kind of inversion and it kind of a
movement From Below all up into the
sacred now
I know that some people might think that
I'm exaggerating but I'm going to show
you a few more images of uh of El Greco
and you'll start to see that this starts
to be a pattern you know and so you can
see again this kind of weird stuff here
you know these seeing right into
underneath the the the the skirts of the
Angels like this one is a little is even
more egregious over here uh and seeing
these these uh these kind of chairs from
behind with their legs up uh it's very
disturbing in terms of what it is
suggesting in terms of
you know in terms of focus and in terms
of what is important
um
now there are more egregious examples in
El Greco I'm going to show you some more
even more egregious examples now these
are the most egregious now in terms of
what exactly is going on in El Greco and
why are we seeing this mannerism what is
involved in the mannerism in terms of a
kind of inversion now the inversion here
appears many ways you know and so you of
course you have Christ resurrecting here
uh and you know this is a despite the
fact that Christ is naked you know there
is a kind of you know there is a kind of
uh
uh you know a centralization the the
character is in the middle he's putting
his hand out there's something about it
which has a Regal quality which isn't
completely weird but then what's going
on over here
why is this character that is upside
down
you know naked with his head from behind
and then you think oh that's strange but
then you realize something's even
strangers going on
what is going on with this person's foot
why is this leg going down in between
the legs of this upside down character
that is there on the ground
you know and you might think well okay
Jonathan you're just seeing things
obviously you're just seeing things you
know but obviously this is happening but
if if it was just this you would think
maybe it's not that big a deal but then
why is this man's sword going up here
so why is it the same guy has this sword
going up into this area
and then at the same time has his foot
going down into the between the legs of
this upside down character now these
this is more than than just a
coincidence and it rep it shows you this
strange kind of upside down thing which
seems to be happening already in in late
Renaissance art you know whether it is
in terms of uh archim bulldoze showing
of the human face made of of uh of
natural things but here you also have a
a strange sexual element to it as well
now
if you look at this image here of course
at the outset you you know I mean this
is military scene and you have uh you
have the angel upskirts a little bit not
as bad as in some of the others we've
seen it's when you look down here the
things start to get strange they're very
strange things going going on down here
it's supposed to be a a kind of
martyrdom where you know people are
being killed but look at here down here
what's going on here and so
um
so if you look at what's going on down
here in the image you have these upside
down decapitated people
and so this
is already something I mean to have the
person upside down and decapitated is
already something but it's not it's not
it becomes a lot weirder when you
realize that this uh decapitated person
El Greco put his head in his crotch
which is like why did he put that
person's head in his crotch uh
and so it's like probably for the same
reason similar reasons is why he did as
why he was doing this uh
I can't imagine anything else and then
when you look at El Greco's image of
Sinai this is when things really kind of
really kind of uh start to appear even
more you really see something like the
let's say the
the winning of the phallic you could say
right the the Sexual Energy kind of
becoming taking over the sacred image uh
you know in the representation in the
way that it's done it's it's it's
difficult to ignore what it is that's
happening in this particular image and
so
the way to see it you know and so
if you still don't believe me like in
terms of what I'm trying to show you
about these images you have to
understand then what happens in the
story of Art and in the history of Art
and how art no longer appears as
integrative no longer appears as
something which is trying to unite
opposites but rather starts to appear as
a form of opposition and this grows of
course not right away it starts to it
starts to take momentum in culture when
you start to see things like Opera
appear when then you start to see things
uh you know in the the
the great painters that are very
legendary in the musicians you start to
see culture as opposition you know as
dialectic rather than culture as unitive
and as bringing opposites together and
so these are opposites of course that
you you will recognize if you're
attentive to to culture and that grows
and grows until in the 20th century you
really reach almost like a a kind of uh
it reaches ahead where all of a sudden
the you know the the culture becomes
dialectic to a point where it it's
almost a caricature and so of course in
these oppositions or in this dialectic
you find the coming about of high art
and low art you know this idea of the
difference between art and craft or art
and folk art uh the difference between
something which is meant to be purely
aesthetic and then something which is
meant to be functional think of how how
boring the industrial objects are and
then think of how at the same time as
this development of the industrial
object there is the fetishization of the
art object which is supposed to be
purely aesthetic without any function in
the world and then you know the
industrially made object which is purely
functional
and doesn't try to have beauty or to try
have any aesthetic uh a purpose and so
of course we have the opposition of Art
and Industry the difference between the
pure expression the pure artist and the
commercial artist uh and and realizing
you have to realize that these all these
opposites didn't exist before didn't
exist before the acceleration of The
Narrative of the Renaissance you could
say into romanticism
um and then into modernism art and
advertisement the difference between
man-made and machine made
etc etc you can look at these opposites
for yourself and then this of course
becomes a there's a kind of pendulum
which starts to swing in culture
between what you could call neoclassical
uh movements and then romantic movements
and so if you look at the Renaissance
and the mannerism then you can kind of
understand that uh that bet that
movement there's a movement towards a
kind of Purity and a kind of excessive
um let's say explicit X
excessive uh order like a kind of weird
tyranny and then in it you also have
this desire to show expressiveness and
and transformation and you see that in
the Arts themselves so if you look at
baroque art for example if you look at a
Rubens you'll notice that it is it looks
chaotic but underneath is this Iron Fist
of geometry and control which wasn't as
much there in the medieval art there was
geometry in medieval art but it wasn't
as as radical as what you end up finding
even in the Roman in even in the Baroque
where the Baroque also looks uh let's
say also looks like it's chaotic so it's
interesting to see those two extremes
appearing even sometimes in the art
itself
um
so this now sets up a kind of dialectic
where now you have a revolutionary
movement in art so you can understand
now when I tried to show you when I
showed you the El Greco ad you can
understand the movement as revolutionary
so here's kind of idiosyncrasy trying to
take the place the the here's desire
this the uh there are different ways to
show the bottom of the pyramid you could
say but always trying to kind of rise up
and take the place of the the tradition
of the tradition and the patterning
this will then kind of appear in the
history of what we could call
avant-gardes and so this idea that now
there are these these new artists that
come about and try to take the The
Narrative from the artist before this is
what we consider to be avant-garde
thinking uh this of course expresses
itself so much in the the impressionist
the Impressionists appear as these
revolutionary figures who are trying to
take the narrative from the the kind of
more uh classically looking you know
academic artists that are there in on
the spot
um and it's and it's important to
understand the themes of the uh of the
art the art becomes more and more about
the common it comes more and more about
everyday life it comes more and more
about uh explicit uh sex sexuality and
sexual encounters and then it also
becomes more and more about the
mechanistic this is one aspect which we
forget about the impressionist is that
they were obsessed with progress and
technology and so you know manes
show this is uh Monet sorry Monet
showing of the the the trains and the
smoke coming out of the trains with this
celebration of technology and of of
technification of society that this can
we often think of the impressionist as
being more you know kind of dreamy and
uh you know and almost opposed to
industrialization and technification but
they go hand in hand and they saw
themselves as going hand in hand
um in this but the in this kind of
separation of high art and low art but
what you see is that in some ways the
low art what is considered low is
constantly trying to be lifted up into
the high despite the opposition that's
the Revolutionary move and so as soon as
you set up this opposition then you see
the the the the the ones below try to
take the top and so the the
Impressionists were on purpose trying to
make paintings that were bothersome to
the elites that didn't have the kind of
smoothness and finesse that you would
see in the uh in the academic painting
uh and all of this in this kind of
desire to create this revolution you can
see of course in Manet you know uh this
image which was so scandalous at the
time and you can understand why with
scandalous you know we're so blase that
we don't realize that to show a woman
the naked in a in a park with two men is
extremely scandalous it's it's a it's
vulgar it's trying to imply all kinds of
uh of sexual things you know and so the
idea that now this is supposed to be
high culture you can understand why it
was resisted but you can also understand
why Manet did it because the very
movement of the art is is revolutionary
the movement of the art is to bring up
the the stuff below bring it up into the
elite and so there's this strange
relationship which continues to have to
happen
this of course goes into absolute
extremes when we come to Modern Art you
know I'm going to look up at a few
add a few images of course was a genius
at this was a genius at at inverting Art
completely and so if you think think of
the the art already of El Greco as a
kind of inversion you know as this
showing of The Angel upskirt and you
know this this this kind of turning
upside down of the figures this these um
these suggestions of sodomy the
suggestion of of
whatever Auto aerotic whatever that
happened in El Greco then become more
and more explicit as the works progress
and when you get to message then of
course this becomes extremely explicit
uh you have
um you have of course the urinal is the
most known of his Works where he just
takes something common but not just
common but something that is there to
receive our our
you know our waste and then prize to
bring it up into the gallery now doing
that is no different than what Monet did
or what Mane did and it honestly I don't
think it's different than what was
happening at the time of the manner is
it's just that this wheel of extreme
Revolution always has to get let's say
move faster and faster and so by the
time you get to to Duchamp then you have
you have these radical moves which is
taking of course the the taking
something that's there to receive waste
and putting it in a gallery to be uh to
be exposed but then also you know the
way that he uses graffiti on what for
them would have been the traditional art
so you have a Leonardo painting which is
considered the height of Art and the
Heart of the height of of traditional
culture even though even at the time it
was it was it's meant to be kind of
disruptive and and a new type of art now
the graffiti on it right then putting an
accident on top you know of marking of
the figuring of desacralizing that art
uh by making the Mona Lisa into a a kind
of transgender character and then of
course in this inscription below
l h o o q it's a French play on words
which is relating to sodomy and so it's
like a joke on sodomy that is being
suggested in in uh duchamp's work
you know and like I said this was this
was in some ways that is the ultimate
move right that's the ultimate uh idea
of Revolution you could say uh and the
same with DeShawn was also obsessed with
the mechanic with mechanical Works
showing this um
the granjat which is supposed to show uh
whatever several sexual encounters
between a woman and and different men
but then that is broken down into
mechanical processes and so this
obsession with the the the the sexuality
but also the mechanics of it the idea of
showing the this stuff down below right
the way that things work and the way
that things work like a bunch of levers
and a bunch of of uh of of biological
processes that are represented as just
mechanics and Industrial mechanics all
right and so this continues there are
many examples Francis piccabia is a
great example because piccabia he he he
was also obsessed with the machine you
know you can see here it says it says
woman man so this is the woman this is
the man and so this is supposed to
represent a sexual encounter that is
mechanized and that is reduced to it to
that kind of mechanistic uh relationship
but piccabia was also really good
because he he had a he had a really good
sense of integrating bad art into the
Fine Art and so he took kitschy art you
know like bad clown art stuff that was
popular culture stuff that wasn't at all
considered to lead and then he tried to
integrate that into high art
um you see this of course he was
painting badly on purpose and was doing
you know these kind of bad faces and
these kind of really bad compositions it
was like bad art but he was trying to
make bad art in order to to bring about
this this revolutionary movement so
think about we know you know and if you
can see it in that line you can see that
there's a coherence in the
Transformations that start in the
Renaissance as a kind of revolutionary
move a move towards idiosyncrasy and
towards showing the lower things and
then those accelerate and accelerate
until you get to this which is in the
very means of art there is a desire to
be crass and to show uh things that
aren't well painted things that are that
are not well composed but then try to
bring that into the the high art and
this of course is just this movement
towards desacralization
I think that it reaches uh an
interesting peak in terms of Andy Warhol
and so Andy Warhol
was a Byzantine Catholic interestingly
enough and so Andy Warhol knew very much
about icon there's there's legends that
he went to church every day which which
maybe I don't know it's possible uh but
nonetheless in his art he he is inspired
by by icons but what he does and so this
is his this was uh Andy warhol's Church
foreign
in New York that he supposedly went to
and so what he does is almost like the
a and a return to iconography or
ultimate de-sacralization is that he
kind of understands in some ways the
language of the icon he in a way that
that the Renaissance artists didn't
totally understand he understands this
idea of of a centralized image of
something which is just framed simply
you know presented to you as something
to look at and then in some ways
something to venerate of course that in
icons but then what he tries to do is he
tries to one bring into the space of the
icon the common and the you know the
glitzy and the the celebrity and then
brings that into the in the way that he
would paint these these celebrities
this kind of simple iconic structure but
then he also makes it reproducible
indefinitely and so at this at the same
time he is kind of has this mechanical
process that he's using and so of course
here they're Campbell soups they're all
different right they're all different
flavors but they they they have this
kind of mechanical reproduction aspect
to them so he's trying to bring in
mechanical reproduction itself into the
art that's why he was using screen
printing he was using these different
mechanical processes to kind of bring
that into the into the art and so you
can see it as a continuation of the
revolution
but what starts to happen in pop art
is very interesting it's very
interesting because what happens in
papart is that they reach into the
opposition of high culture low culture
Elite you know High art low art uh
Gallery Art popular art and they try of
course again to invert the relationship
you know until then popular art was
still seen as emanating from high art it
was still seen as in this opposition it
was seen as being influenced from that
which is above and now all of a sudden
there's a very interesting idea which is
that the low art starts to become the
influence of the high art and so there's
a desire to completely invert the
relationship of art which is you know by
making popular industrial things it was
already there right and it was already
there in piccabia and in but then in
Warhol it becomes very explicit and and
becomes a a technique that he uses over
and over
um
and so but then this is where it starts
to get even funnier and where I think
there is a surprising
there is a surprising shift that happens
you know and so
the the common object
the the this can of soup is an object of
participation that is eating food is
still something that we can claim is
participative you know there is
something uh So when you buy a can of
soup and you open it and then you eat
the contents it is not that that
contemplative thing that high art had
been from kind of accelerating from the
mo time of the Renaissance because one
of the oppositions that happens is to
make things that are useless right these
paintings don't have uses in the world
they are they are just objects of
contemplation they're not like the
ancient images that were there to
celebrate God they're not like the
ancient objects that were there to
participate in the life of an aristocrat
or in the life of a you know to
celebrate the hunt or to celebrate
things that that that the people
participated in or a dance music or
whatever it is that was there these are
these are dogs become useless and this
is of course the the thing that dusha is
doing himself which is taking a useful
object and making it useless uh you know
but then that's the weird thing that
happens when you get to there so as if
you're getting to the bottom you're at
the bottom of the process and now you're
basically trying to take the lowest
thing you can and try to put it at the
top uh and then I think a flip happens
and I think it happens in in Warhol
interestingly enough interestingly
enough and so uh like I said you know a
urinal is an object of participation
it's a low object of participation but
it is and so it's like trying to take
that which is still low and
participative and make it useless
uh
Warhol is doing the same trying to take
that which is low and participative uh
and try to bring it up into Elite
culture and then also making it useless
making it more valuable at least in the
elitist eyes
then something weird happens which is
that Campbell
starts to make cans of soup that are
based on warhol's designs
and so what's just happened
what just happened
all of a sudden there's this strange
reintegration
because
in some ways what Warhol is trying to do
is to praise the soup can
praise the common make it bring it up
into into the the elite space but he's
also denaturing it while he's doing it
but then all of a sudden there's this
flip where now warhol's designs of the
Soup cans get put on the actual cans and
so you can go to the store and then you
can buy an Andy Warhol soup can and you
can eat the food inside the soup can
and there it starts to happen weirdly in
in other artists as well another pop
artist especially so Keith Herring is a
good example where Keith Herring is
still a gallery artist he's still making
art for
um
you know that have a kind of elitist
thing but because he wants to fully
invert the process because in some ways
he he wants to be the punk rocker who is
you know who is with the people and you
know elevating the people into this High
cultural space he starts to enter into
the space of participation and then does
you know a lot of these artists even up
to Warhol uh
would have been cautious at making like
t-shirts and and and selling selling
objects that had their images on them
because in some ways
it's a dangerous thing if you want to
stay up in the elite but of course it
hap it happens anyways with this strange
flip of of Campbell's soup using his
designs but then it keeps hearing he was
doing it himself which is that he was
selling T-shirts with his art he was
putting it on skateboards on different
different objects and so he was kind of
bringing the the the low art itself was
starting to be revalued a participative
art or a more a low art and the the
relationship of the inversion started to
become messy
and you see this thing happened in
Liechtenstein so Liechtenstein is this
artist here who would copy
um comic book panels and would would
make them into paintings you know
um
and so he was trying to take papart and
elevate it into the cultural space still
maintaining the opposition which is
something that happens all the time but
then at some point that opposition just
collapses and then you have pieces for
example this this um this one page of
Spider-Man sold for what like two
million dollars which is just a page
from a comic book that is not high art
that is actually low art but now is
being treated like high art itself uh
and so it collapses the it collapses the
opposite ultimately in terms of let's
say the flip actually happens the
inversion completely happens because
these other inversions
they they constantly need the duality in
order to function and so then the
collapse of the invert of The Duality
and things like this
you know Point towards what we could
call a reintegration it's not totally
yet a reintegration
um
and you see something strange of course
in Warhol happening in in the in some of
his work you know here you could say
something that like this is the ultimate
de-sacralization Warhol did quite a bit
of religious art but then his art is of
course to manifest the reproducibility
you know the mechanical reproduction of
the art object you know very much in
line with some of the early theorists
talked about this
Walter Benjamin who is a
who was a a German uh I think I think he
was Jewish uh thinker you know that's
considered kind of like post-war thinker
or during World War II and post-war
thinker he really called he was a
communist he really called to the um
the the movement towards mechanical art
and reproducible art in order to destroy
the sacred he really understood that
this would destroy the very idea of the
Sacred but but then in in Warhol you
have this weird thing where he brings
that to it's extreme but then
it's like it's just so weird it's so
weird then they make last year there was
a show I think in Brooklyn of Andy
warhol's religious art they call it Andy
were all Revelation and so it's just
fascinating to realize that it's like
why are you making a show about Andy
warhol's religious art
because his art is about this kind of
leveling you can see it in the work
right it's like here is you know a
Renaissance image of the Virgin and
child you know that next to it has just
a kind of
you know grocery store price tag which
is kind of glued next to it but there's
something strange going on in terms of
the collapse
of the opposite and then a kind of
desire to reaffirm the sacred in the
very collapse
and this is something you know you know
I've talked about this weird idea how
this kind of double inversion you see
that like in the The Soup cans
especially but something happened
recently interestingly enough uh
at uh at my house I got a letter
from um
I got a letter from the local church you
know and I don't know how ironic this
was or how conscious it was but
nonetheless
it happened you know and I got a letter
from the church and it was a letter to
ask people to tithe you know because
there are still a lot of uh Catholics in
Quebec and so they kind of send a letter
out in the city to ask people to give
their tithe and then on the letter was
was Buddy Jesus I swear on the letter
was Buddy Jesus
and uh you know this image is of course
used was used to kind of mock the the
Catholic church for trying to be cool
for trying to to to make its art
accessible to people uh and then this
priest uses the very image that was used
to mock them
and then uses it as an image for asking
people to die for the church now like I
said I don't totally know how conscious
the priest was of whether or not you
know
maybe he is so like Vatican to guitar
mass that he thinks this is okay which
is hilarious uh or he's a little
conscious of what's going on and he's
using the imagery of mockery in order to
kind of reappeal to participation now
I don't I the the the the jury is out on
that but I think that the fact that it
happened is still pointing towards a a
notion of this kind of flip now
you know it's important to understand
that this is there in Christianity
itself that this is in some ways
part of the Christian story we have to
understand that there is a great
desacralization in the Christian story
you know and that desirilization is of
course the the crucifix itself uh and
and the the way in which the modern
world
move towards desacralization
is in some ways a parody of this You
Know parody of the crucifixion
maybe there might be something more
mysterious going on but we have to
understand that there is of course this
movement in the Christian in the
Christian tradition it's kind of move
towards idiosyncrasy you know and then
like I've mentioned many times before
this the surprising aspect of how Christ
in the fact that he's derided in the
fact that there is this mocking of him
as a king the fact that he's given a
crown of thorns gets ultimately
transformed by Christ into Glory so I
think that that's an interesting thing
that happens and I think that
it's the the very process of trying to
revolutionize constantly there is a
moment where where we get to the bottom
of that and there's a
there's a switch that happened and I
think this switch
um opens up
some interesting possibilities to deal
with questions of the whole history of
Art and how it can be reintegrated in
the proper way and so if you want to
understand what I'm doing
you can you can understand it like that
you can understand that in some ways I
feel like my work and it's not just me
there's several artists out there I
think of father siluana justiniano and
other iconographers that have come out
of Contemporary Art and now see the
possibility at the end of Contemporary
Art to in some ways reintegrate
uh reintegrate art into life and
reintegrate and understand how this is
what art calls us what art is calling at
this moment to become and so
if you look at my work through that lens
you'll understand a lot of the things
that I'm doing and a lot of the
different things that I'm doing and so
I do think that there is a possibility
of reintegrating art into life and to do
it at different levels and to do it in a
kind of hierarchy you know a hierarchy
which even takes into account the
developments of of pop art the
developments of uh of Contemporary Art
um
but I do think that there is now a
possibility to reformulate
a reintegration of the hierarchy of of
values and that of course has to do with
something like appropriate Beauty for
the appropriate thing it has to do with
the message but also the function that's
why of course I'm making sacred art
uh that's very important and so if I
make a reliquary you know this is being
used in a church you know this is not
this is not
um and in and what I'm doing is I'm also
taking the ancient art and I'm
reintegrating it in a way that is that
is also never seen before this of course
no one has ever made a relic query that
looks that has this together it's a
reintegration of these ancient things
towards a purpose towards participation
in the world uh and considering a
certain hierarchy you know and so
depending on what it is you're making
the materials the the vision that you're
trying to bring to it will be
appropriate to it and if you think of
you know here are here's a
funerary monument and an altar
um I can estas this cross across that
goes at the top of the acostasis that
tries to integrate materiality and and
the Christian Vision into something
which is going to participate in reality
but there's also a kind of possibility
of reintegrating
hierarchy so when you make when you make
a soup can
you have to consider the materials
you're making based on the purpose that
it has and so if Andy Warhol can make a
screen print of a soup can and it's kind
of arbitrary maybe not completely but
kind of then once they take Andy Warhols
um design and they make it a soup can
out of it then they have to make the
soup can out of aluminum or tin they
have to make the paper out of of paper
you know they have to put the soup
inside the can the soup can be made of
paint or else people won't buy it people
won't eat it and so there is a there's a
possibility and the same with Keith
Herring like if Keith Herring made a
skateboard with his print designs on it
he couldn't make the skateboard out of
something ridiculous he has to make the
skateboard out of something that can be
written if you make a t-shirt you have
to make the T-shirt out of something
that can be worn you can't make a
t-shirt you know out of some imaginary
artistic creative thing or else people
won't buy the t-shirt and so that's what
I mean by this kind of reintegration so
there's a kind of new hierarchy possible
which takes into account
the the the function of materiality you
know the symbolism of materials
themselves what their purposes are and
what they can be used for and so you
have this this great thing and then you
you have the possibility of creating a
kind of hierarchy again
between handmade to Mechanical objects
all the way down into digital objects so
you make and if you're going to make a
unique piece for a church that is that
that is going to go into the altar you
know if you make uh you make a a
precious image using semi-precious
stones using uh gold using all these
these techniques that are unique and
they're kind of pointing up towards uh
participation in worship
um but then also uniqueness then you're
not afraid to also kind of devolve that
into into other things and so you know
if you make if you make a T-shirt If you
make a print
you can use some of the same images you
can use some of this similar similar
tropes
um but then they get applied differently
depending on the purpose that you're
trying to apply them
and so and then you can also use so here
I wanted to show how I use similar
images similar structures as my
iconography to make a secular image of a
siren and then if I apply this type of
thinking to prints and to t-shirts
then I applied appropriately to that
level and the same goes for here's
another example where I made a kind of
semi-precious image in terms of the
angel
and then the same on a t-shirt gets
applied appropriately and mechanically
and that's okay because it's not it's
not meant this object is not meant to be
liturgical and it doesn't have enough to
be liturgical in its in its uh in its
structure
here's another example of course that
helps you show the shift between
purposes and how they get integrated and
people you know and then even in terms
of imagery the the let's say the imagery
that I use is different and so when I
make an image for a church I will of
course
let's say use sacred imagery very
clearly have inscriptions there are kind
of rules that you use in order to make
um images for churches and then as you
move down towards let's say more popular
art and and clothing for example I would
make what I could call Semi icons
they're not icons in the sense that you
know these figures are not people that
are represented they are they are kind
of they are allegorical or they're
analogical representations of the
Evangelist
um and then angels are also not this is
not a representation of a person say
Michael
say Michael doesn't wear an armor and he
doesn't he doesn't uh have wings this
way you know this is the way that we
represent Angels is analogical and so
that's why in my t-shirts I tend to have
things that are semi icons that are not
icons in the traditional sense you'll
never see me making a t-shirt of Christ
you know just with his Halo uh it'll
always be something that is mitigated
you know and so if I make an image of
the when I made the image of the um
an image of the the of everything you
know the the faces they're not
completely done I try to I leave some
elements out of the face in order to not
to not for people not to mistake this
with an icon to be venerated
um
there are different techniques that I
use in order to try to make something
like semi-sacred images that are lower
on the hierarchy but still participate
and still remember you know and then of
course going all the way down into pop
art uh then of course the you know as
you know the um
the the making of of God's dog was about
that was about you know can we get all
the way down into very popular
um
popular art that is remembering its
connection to the sacred that is
participating in it but at its level it
isn't you know it isn't uh it isn't
these aren't icons these aren't meant to
be liturgical and that's why they're
also printed mechanically that's why
um they're drawn in a way that is more
sensuous that is closer to the
Renaissance tradition further from the
further from the iconographic tradition
but that's the idea that's the
interesting possibility is that in some
ways we have the the the the possibility
of kind of moving
away from the irony that came about
through this whole history this
revolutionary aspect and tried to
reintegrate things at the proper level
where where where they belong or where
they should be and of course there could
be discussion about where things should
be and I know some people think that I'm
going too far with my
um with my popular art in terms of the
images I use but I think that that's a
discussion that will happen and there'll
be some play
um but the thrust
I think is important the thrust of
thinking about this of re of
understanding how we can reappropriate
participative art in different ways
um I think it's very important and I
think in some ways the state of
Contemporary Art almost calls to that
right we're at that level where the
irony is so strong the inversion is so
strong uh but then there's also a weird
moment of of double inversion that's
happening that's kind of calling towards
new participation
so hope this was helpful and interesting
in order to kind of understand you know
why I'm doing the things I'm doing but
also how the history of Western Art has
a coherence when you start to think
about it in terms of this simple
revolutionary move which started I think
somewhere around the time of the
Renaissance and continued until today so
thanks everybody for your attention I'll
talk to you very soon